I often say that we have to use our wise
as a filter that it should serve as the
context but the decisions we make but it
raises a very practical question how do
you do that well it's like a lot of
things we have filters for all kinds of
things every day of our lives where we
use these things to us you know to
decide if we think something is right or
wrong we have it we have a moral compass
we have a moral codes when someone asks
us to do something illegal or something
that would hurt somebody else we don't
we don't have to sit and read the law to
decide whether we can or kind of do this
we have a moral compass that says yeah
I'm gonna pass on that that that doesn't
sit well with me that doesn't fit with
Who I am or how I was raised right in
other words we have these moral
compasses well the wise serves exactly
the same thing when we are clear on our
why it's as if that compass that moral
compass is right in front of us so when
someone asks us to do something we can
actually see if it's saying yes this
will help with this no this won't help
so very often someone come to me and say
we want you to come and help our company
and I'll say great so tell me tell me
what so what's your cause what's your
company's why why do you do what you do
and then they'll say something like our
company's wise to increase the bottom
line at any expense because we want to
be the biggest most successful company
our industry now my compass is spinning
all around I'm going whoa let me tell
you what I believe and I believe in
people I believe in looking after your
human beings I believe in serving your
employees oh yeah you know we think
that's important too you can see
immediately the thing that I put as
priority number one that they prayed put
his part number 80232 for I'm not gonna
have a good time with these guys and and
we're not going to align so I'll usually
pass on something like that that's an
example of me using my why to help me
make a decision the hard part is
sometimes you know there's a lot of
money or benefits or perks that are
offered and those things are super
tempting and that's why these things are
hard that's why these things are hard do
we have the strength of character to
turn down a bounty to do something that
we not only know is right but more
importantly that brings us happiness joy
and fulfillment and those are really
really hard decisions
mean to minimize them at all but that's
sort of how a Wye serves as context we
use it as a moral compass and the more
clearly that Y is articulated the easier
it is to see that compass